[Music]
so you know there are elements in my
character that are optimistic you know
I've looked for example I worked for a
UN Committee and on the relationship
between economic development
sustainability and I found out a variety
of things that we're very optimistic
like the fact that you know the UN set
out to have poverty between 2000 and
2015 worldwide and actually hit that by
about 2010 right so we're in that period
of the fastest transformation of the
bottom strata of the world's population
into something approximating middle
class that's ever occurred and there's
all these great technological
innovations on the horizon and it looks
to me like things could go
extraordinarily well if we were careful
but I'm not optimistic and maybe that's
me I'm pessimistic because I also see
that there's five or six things
happening all of which appear at the
level of catastrophe that are all
happening at the same time and so one of
the things that I'd like to ask you is
like what do you see happening in the
next 10 years in the universities are in
culture at large and I mean you just put
forward a proposal for the universities
for the treatment of women which i think
is a very interesting one because women
do have a different time frame than men
but like what the hell is the proper way
forward I've been encouraging young men
to tell the truth and to take
responsibility and there's a huge market
for that message but but I'm not
convinced by any stretch of the
imagination that it's enough what like
when you look forward and you try to be
optimistic what the hell do you see well
and in the largest you know scale I'm
concerned about the future Western
culture because as a student of history
it looks too much to me like ancient
Rome okay which became over expanded
which became it was at the mercy of a
bureaucratic creep okay and and in the
and Roman identity eventually got
blurred okay
in its incorporation of so many
different cultures which I first seems
like a healthy kind of multiculturalism
but eventually over expand and simply
collapse of its own the way so III and I
so I am concerned about the you know
whether Western culture is in a rapid
decline I think it would be very easy
because we are you know so
interconnected and so over complex very
easy to bring it to ruin it would only
take one major natural disaster you know
to do that but the universities
themselves I mean I think people are all
of a sudden in the United States much
more attentive to issues of political
correctness because of the the riots at
Berkeley which was the you know which
was the capital free speech I mean I
mean the the Free Speech Movement
happened in the spring before I entered
college in nineteen sixty forty one of
the great principles and inspirational
stories of my entire life Mario Savio is
you know you know assertion of the of
the supremacy of you know free thought
and free speech he's okay and I so I
think that perhaps you know we might
just have turned a corner and but it's
gonna take a very very long time for the
university to be reformed I feel and
that the cafeteria menu
okay of the university curriculum has to
be abandoned we must return to
historical courses that begin in a in
the earliest period in the Stone Age in
antiquity in order to give perspective
you know to to our to our present to an
analysis of a person a culture I want
fifty fifty to seventy five percent of
college administrators fired okay and
the money be transferred over okay to to
to faculty into the libraries and to
into to instruction okay
I think that you know the obviously the
way things are being people are being a
trained right now including at the
public school level okay is I think that
I think the public school level has gone
to hell yeah when my twin twin when my
mother came you know came to United
States the age of six there was the old
public school system was so very strict
and therefore if she had excellent
education you know it's a and you know
didn't got all A's and in her in her and
even though she started out not speaking
English spoke without an accent etc okay
so today this
to feel good the public school education
which is which is a form of ideologies
and indoctrination right now it's all
about no bullying okay and not about it
not even seriously about no bullying yes
so I mean I can tell in my own students
I mean I've been teaching for 46 years
so I can tell the this slow degradation
of public school education get to the
point now that the students have
absolutely no sense of world geography
of world history they know absolutely on
the net they don't know anything about
wars okay and the reality the barbaric
reality of most of human history and
when it whatever defense that's
triggering yes right what a fantastic
culture we live in and so you know it
doesn't identity politics itself has
just got to stop I mean it was important
once okay again I I was a rebel against
the the wasp you know hegemony okay
white anglo-saxon Protestant of Germany
in American culture it was it was
suffocating III was raised in the 1950s
where they went when wasps control
corporations and and and education and
politics so any identity politics was
necessary once okay to it we asserted
getting gay rights okay and he was into
Stonewall Rebellion of 1969 we have so
we asserted okay the women's rights with
thee with with the rebirth of second
wave feminism in the late 1960s okay but
this endless ok preoccupation with with
a fragmented identity we must return to
be authentic nineteen sixties vision
which is about identity coming from
consciousness which transcends gender
which transcends all these divisions of
race okay and the ethnicity okay
consciousness itself okay right there's
no sense of that any longer and that's
what this 1960s thought well I see if
that is a complete abandonment of
personal responsibility because that
like that consciousness I think
symbolically and I got a lot of this
from young and also from Eric Norman I
mean that's the great logos of the West
right that's the transcendent principle
which is is respect for the primacy of
individual consciousness and what goes
along with that primarily isn't
individual rights although that's built
into it I mean that's the reason we have
individual rights is for respect for
that but the responsibility that comes
along with being an individual instead
the member of some group especially a
victimized group which is like that sure
I wrote an article with one of my
students who had toured the mass grave
sites in in the former Yugoslavia you
know what haven't been exposed to that
sort of thing and one of the things that
our research indicated was that the best
predictor of genocide is victimization
on the part of the group that produces
the genocide right a sense of an
accelerated sense of victimization and
then it's well we get them before they
get us
so and everyone's being taught now that
they're a victim and then no one seems
to have any sense that you know that's
part of the essential tragedy of being
that life is suffering and that and that
and that and and that the world rests on
a foundation of suffering it's nothing
to take personally and something to take
responsibility for instead of blaming
and and resentment and all of the things
that have polluted our universities and
our culture